[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Today, we're
hosting Luis Fernando Garcia.
Luis Fernando Garcia
is the director
for the [SPANISH],, which
broadly translates to English
as the Digital Right Network.
And they're tasked with
defending the digital rights
in Mexico.
And to that end,
they've conducted
a series of
initiatives, among which
they have an initiative that
tries to track surveillance.
And today, Luis will talk to
us about some research effort
that they started some
months ago that led
to some interesting
revelations about how
the Mexican government
surveils individuals in Mexico.
And with that, I'll
turn it over to Luis.
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA: Hi,
thank you for having me.
Thank you for
Google to invite me.
I'm Luis Fernando Garcia.
And I'm the director of
[SPANISH],, a digital rights
defense network from Mexico.
We are an NGO--
nonprofit-- that we do
research, litigation, advocacy,
communications strategies, to
try to promote a human rights
perspective on the interactions
between humans and technology.
We work on different
range of issues,
from privacy and surveillance--
which is what I will be talking
about right now--
to other issues of freedom
of expression online,
on access to the internet, on
access to knowledge, et cetera.
So just a little bit of
background about Mexico.
Not everyone is
always aware of what's
happening in other countries.
But in Mexico, there is
a government right now
that has been five
years on and that
has been riddled with
scandals from the start.
It's been a government
that has been--
the government right
now has around 10%
approval rating,
which is pretty low.
And the reason why they got
there is because there's
been scandals and
corruption, human rights
abuses, and there's been
a lot of turmoil in Mexico
about the situation in Mexico.
And this context is important
to understand the rest
of the story that I will tell.
But I probably will
explain some other events
that have been happening in
Mexico, to give some context.
So the presentation that
I prepared for you today,
it's called [SPANISH],,
which translates
to Spying Government.
And it's about how we've
been uncovering and resisting
illegal surveillance in Mexico.
Our organization is
actually pretty young.
We didn't exist three years ago.
And in that time, 2014,
we started precisely
because there was a problem.
There was a
telecommunications law
being discussed in Congress.
And we were very worried
that issues of surveillance,
of privacy and freedom
expression online,
were not going to be part of
the discussion in the Congress.
So we got together.
And we didn't have a website
or a logo or anything.
We just tried to do
what we could to promote
a prospective of human rights.
And one of the issues
that we were worried
is, what was privacy?
The telecommunications
law that was proposed
expanded surveillance
in various ways
that we felt it was dangerous.
But first, there's one thing
that it's important to--
maybe, it's obvious
for some people.
But I don't want to stop
myself from saying it.
The difficulty to
research, to do advocacy,
to handle surveillance
as a society
has its own particularities.
For one, it's a tool
that is highly invasive.
It is highly powerful.
The person that can have access
to other people's information
has lots of power
over that person.
But at the same
time, surveillance
that is carried out by the
state, normally and naturally,
is carried out in secret.
So there is a problem here.
Because normally, when there
are abuses by the government,
there are ways in which at
least we can be aware of it.
And you can, maybe,
try to challenge it.
If the police enters your
house without a warrant
or you get detained, at least
you know you're being detained.
You know your house was entered.
And you can do
something about it.
In the case of
surveillance, you don't
know that the government's
spying on you.
And it's difficult
for you to know.
It's difficult for you to
research it, to resist it.
And this presents
a set of issues
that needs the
law and technology
and society in general--
treat this problem differently
than other civil rights
problems.
In 2014, when we started
working on surveillance,
there was this trend.
There was this trend-- there
were very strong security
narratives.
I will explain a couple of them.
But basically-- and probably,
people that are from the US
have experienced
this since 2001--
there's all this
narrative of asking
you to lose civil liberties
in exchange for security,
and all this emotional
blackmail that happens.
And of course, there is
a bit of true to that.
But there is this push,
by these narratives,
to try to increase
the power of the state
and decrease the civil
liberties that citizens
have to resist it.
So with this narrative,
there's also been, since 2009,
probably, another
piece of context.
Since 2007, violence in
Mexico increased dramatically.
The government and the army
started fighting drug cartels.
And since then, there's
been a lot of violence.
And this has fueled
these narratives.
And in this context,
the government
has been seeking more
powers, more authorities,
to do surveillance.
And they have
requested and pushed
for less controls,
less accountability,
because what they say is
they want to act faster
and they want to
protect the people.
Basically, there are two
very strong narratives
that have been used to promote
more surveillance and less
controls.
One-- I like to call it--
this one-- won't somebody
please think of the children?
There's an emotional appeal.
Like, we need to give government
these tools, because won't
somebody think of the children?
They are in danger.
And the other one,
it's when you explain
that the problems
that can happen
if the government
or any entity has
too much power into the lives of
people without accountability,
particularly with this problem
that invasions of privacy
are often hidden from the public
eye, you are labeled as someone
like him--
like, tinfoil hat and paranoid.
And this was what we
were against in 2014.
We had these very
strong narratives behind
and pushing massive
surveillance and less controls.
And in the end, the
basic things that we
had approved by Congress
is this [INAUDIBLE] thing
where mass surveillance-- we
got their attention mandates.
We had a vagueness about who
can carry out surveillance.
For example, the law said--
it established a lot
of surveillance tools
or techniques and said that
any competent authority
could use this.
And we said, when this
discussion was in Congress,
you need to define, who
is a competent authority?
You cannot just leave
it open like that.
And they said, no, no.
We're going to
leave it like that.
Because other law says what
is a competent authority.
Well, this is what we said.
And we'll see if we
were right or wrong.
If you leave it like this, a
lot of authorities will say,
I'm a competent authority.
I'm interpreting it like
And then a lot of authorities--
local, federal, municipal--
will feel entitled or
authorized by the law
to carry out surveillance.
The same with
judicial oversight.
In the Constitution
of Mexico, to do
a traditional lawful
intercept of communications,
you need a federal
judge to approve it.
With regard to other
types of surveillance,
like location
tracking in real time
or to access communications
metadata from people,
the law was delivered to be
left in a very vague space,
in a very gray area.
We said, you need to establish
very clearly that you
need a warrant for this.
And they said, we're
going to leave it
like that, because I
want this room to, maybe,
don't get a warrant.
There was also lack
of transparency, lack
of independent supervision.
In some countries,
there are authorities
in charge of supervising
these authorities
and trying to force them to
have some type of accountability
with all it's discharging
cases, et cetera.
Or the right to identification--
in some countries,
as well, there is
a right for you
to know that you were
surveilled at one point.
And maybe you are not told
during the surveillance
because, maybe, in
some cases, that
could frustrate the legitimate
objective of the surveillance.
But you are told, at one
point, hey, six months ago,
we were doing our investigation.
And we did surveillance on you.
And if you think
it was an abuse,
you can do something about it.
Well, none of those
safeguards that
had been identified and
applied in many countries
were present in Mexican law.
So with these very bad
laws, with these very strong
narratives in place--
somebody please think of
the children and, if you do
something about it, you are a
paranoid tinfoil-hat person--
we asked, how can we
change the narrative?
How can we produce change
and make law-makers--
but society in general--
understand that this is a very
dangerous place in which we
were and which we are?
So what we did is a
range of activities.
With did litigation.
And this law that was passed,
we challenged it in court.
We also did advocacy
in Congress,
trying to establish at
least some safeguards.
And we had limited success.
A few years later,
like, a year and a half
ago, there were some
transparency laws
approved that established, now,
obligations for authorities
and even for telecommunication
companies to provide
detailed transparency reports--
statistical data mainly.
But also, for example,
telecommunication companies
need to say who has asked
them for information
and how many times and how
many times they have said yes
and how many times
they have said no.
And this does not
solve the problem.
But you will see, it helps.
It gives you indication that,
maybe, things can go wrong
or things are going right.
The same with
judicial oversight,
but we'll leave that story
for a little bit later.
We also started to use,
like FOIA here in the US--
access to affirmation
laws in Mexico,
which are pretty decent, to
try to get more information.
And we tried to know
what was going on,
who was using surveillance,
how many times, et cetera.
We tried to create evidence that
the problems that we identified
in the law when it was passed
were actually materializing
into real problems.
And we also tried to document
and to research technologies
being used and cases of abuse,
which is difficult in general.
For example, with the access
to information requests,
we asked thousands of requests
to authorities all over Mexico
to try to understand stuff
like, who is doing surveillance?
Are they doing it with
judicial oversight?
Is it effective?
Are there inconsistencies in
the data that we're getting?
Many of these requests turned
into hundreds of lawsuits.
And for example,
one of these cases
even got into the Supreme Court.
Fortunately, we won.
We wanted the NSA of Mexico--
is to call CISEN--
to tell us how many people
they have surveilled.
I don't want their
names or anything.
I just want to know how many
did you surveil in 2014.
And they didn't want to
give us that information.
It went into the Supreme Court.
And fortunately, we won.
And now-- well, December
of last year we won.
And they haven't told us yet.
But supposedly, we won.
And they will tell us.
But we'll see.
So after all these
requests and all the data
that we were able to gather,
we found a lot of problems.
And here's a few findings.
Sorry, some of the
charts are in Spanish.
But yeah, I will explain them.
No problem.
For example, this chart--
this chart shows three federal
authorities, the National
Security Agency,
the Federal Police,
and the Federal Prosecutor.
We asked them how
many times they
have asked a judge to authorize
them to carry out surveillance.
But we also asked the courts.
And we told them, how many
times have this guy come to you
and asked for authorization?
And we got totally different
results, depending who you ask.
For example, the National
Security Agency of Mexico
told us that,
between 2013 in 2015,
they requested of court
to authorize surveillance
a little bit over 2,000 times.
But the courts say, no.
That guy only came 654 times.
And for example, the
federal prosecutor or, like,
the Department of Justice--
similar in Mexico-- it was
completely the opposite.
They said that
they did only 866.
But the court said, no,
he came 2,392 times.
And this is just requests.
We did other
exercise in which we
were able to identify that,
in average, by each request,
these authorities get
authorization to surveil
on between 7 and 10 people.
So it's important.
2,000 is 2,000 people?
No, 2,000 requests
which, probably, you
can multiplicate that
for 7, 8, 9, 10 times,
depending on the year.
So this doesn't
prove, necessarily,
that they are using it
against people they shouldn't.
But this just tells
you, something is wrong.
Something's not
functioning well here.
And there's another thing.
For example, we asked,
how many times--
well, we were worried about--
the law doesn't say clearly
that you need a warrant.
But you told us that it did.
But we told you, it's not clear.
It's not clear for companies.
It's not clear for authorities.
And when we asked,
how many times did you
have access to
communications metadata
from telecommunications users?
From cell phone users?
Close to 99% of the time,
they did it without a warrant.
What we said was going
to happen and they
said it wasn't going
to happen happened.
99% of the time, an authority
went to your cell phone
provider, asked for your data.
And cell phone provider
just gave it away
without a warrant--
another finding.
For example, we analyzed the
free transparency reports
from the telecommunication
companies.
And we saw that, for
example, in Mexico, there
are basically three
main cell phone
carriers, one very big one--
but basically, it
was a monopoly--
it still has most
of the market--
which is called Telecel.
It was the property
of one of the richest
men in the world, Carlos Slim.
And there's AT&T. And there's
Telefonica, a Spanish company.
AT&T, for example, rejects
around 46% of the requests
they get from authorities.
This means that
they get a request.
And they analyze it.
And sometimes, they say yes.
Sometimes, they say
no, as it should.
Telefonica-- it's less.
But still, they reject some.
But the biggest cell
phone company in Mexico,
which is Telecel, never
rejected one request.
So anyone who said, I'm
a competent authority,
without a warrant, give
me your data, got it.
Among those-- a bunch
of these authorities--
some that have not been
identified-- but these
are names of authorities that
do not have any legal basis
to do any type of surveillance,
electoral commissions,
local police, the Communications
Ministry, the governor of one
state, et cetera.
This, again, all
these statistics
point to something that is very
wrong, that authorities that
don't have a clear legal
mandate to do surveillance
are doing it without
a warrant, in secret,
with no accountability.
It's a recipe for disaster.
And also, as I
mentioned before, we
wanted to test this
claim that surveillance
is so important and so
necessary to prosecute crime.
We asked prosecutors
all around the country,
how many investigations
have you use surveillance?
And what happens with
those investigations?
Do they get someone in jail?
Or not?
Well, over 90% of
the investigations
in which a prosecutor
used surveillance,
that investigation
either remains open
or didn't turn out into
charging anyone with any crime.
So it's safe to say
that more than 90%
of the people that
were surveilled
in the context of a
criminal investigation
were never charged of any crime.
Which, again, mounts
data and evidence
that there's
something very wrong
and that the claim
that surveillance
is super useful in
Mexico, at least,
for criminal investigations,
is at least an overstate.
So we used this
research in litigation.
And it was very useful.
We were able to get the
Supreme Court to say, OK, OK.
I'm going to say who is
a competent authority.
And that's it.
And they reduced
it to, basically,
two groups of authorities,
either the Federal
Police, the National Security
Agency at the federal level,
and the prosecutors, for
investigating crimes--
and always with a warrant.
That was something that the
court said, thanks to the case
that we brought to the court.
So it's clear, now,
that you need a warrant
to get the content,
to get metadata,
and also to get the
location tracking
of a person in real time.
This was something that the
court didn't say you needed.
But we managed to convince
Congress to pass a law
to require it as well.
So now, it's clear, at least in
the law, maybe not in practice.
But it's clear that
you need a warrant.
And if you don't get a warrant
to do any type of surveillance
in Mexico and if you are not
one of these authorities,
then the surveillance
you are doing is illegal.
But still, these
narratives remain.
Because you haven't
proved that these
have been used against someone
that shouldn't have been used.
We just have data and then
suggestions and suspicions
which are, I think,
grounded in some evidence.
But we haven't found--
some people just don't
care unless you show them
where the victim is.
So that's what we try to
work on, finding victims.
How can we document?
How can we create stories?
And how can we show, in flesh,
how surveillance looks like?
And how the surveillance that
we presumed was being abused--
because all these
data pointed to that--
how can we prove
and find someone
that shouldn't have been
surveilled that was surveilled?
Some of our first indications
that this might be happening
and that, actually,
surveillance was starting
to become more
sophisticated in Mexico
was documenting the
acquisition and use
of more sophisticated
surveillance tools,
like malware.
Here in the US,
the NSA, the FBI,
they probably build
their own malware
and their own
surveillance tools.
But in other countries,
like Mexico, they
buy it from other companies.
So there's a company in
Italy called Hacking Team.
And the Hacking Team got hacked.
And all their data
was published,
their e-mails, their
contracts, and their Twitter
account, actually, for
more than 12 hours.
And in that data, it showed
that Mexico was the biggest
client of Hacking Team.
It was the one that
spent the most money.
Even more than-- in this
chart, you will see,
Mexico is way, way the biggest
client of Hacking Team,
but also in the
number of authorities.
We've found contracts with
several local governors
and authorities that are
not part of those groups
that the Supreme Court
has said are the only ones
that can do surveillance.
You can find
several police even.
An oil company bought
surveillance malware
from this company, et cetera.
In one case, for
example, we were
able to prove that the
governor of one of the biggest
states in Mexico, Jalisco,
where tequila comes from,
bought Hacking Team malware.
And we proved that--
technically, the prosecutor of
Jalisco can do surveillance.
But the government of Jalisco
can't do surveillance.
And we proved that who bought it
was the government of Jalisco.
They installed it,
even, in a building
that is part of the government
of Jalisco, not the prosecutor.
But when we
discovered this, they
said, first, no, it's not true.
When we showed the contract,
the signature of the official
from the government,
they said, OK.
We bought it.
But we bought it
for the prosecutor.
And we gave it to them.
And then we cross-reference the
information with information
that we got from the access
to information requests.
And we found that the
federal prosecutor has only
requested a court to authorize
surveillance three times.
And that's according
to the prosecutor.
Because according
to courts, they
have never come
for authorization
to surveil anyone.
But let's take their word.
They don't deserve it.
Three times, in three
years, you surveil a person.
And let's assume that
those three times
were with this malware.
There's two scenarios.
Either you spent
millions of dollars
in acquiring very highly
sophisticated malware
to use it on three people.
Or you're using it without
a warrant and illegally.
Both scenarios are horrible.
Either you're
incompetent and corrupt.
Or you are incompetent,
corrupt, and a criminal.
This showed us that there
was this big market,
there was this big
hunger in Mexico
for acquiring these
tools and for using it
against who knows who.
And then it came--
him.
Him is Ahmed Mansoor.
He is, actually, right
now, a political prisoner
in the United Arab Emirates.
And he has been under
surveillance by the United Arab
Emirates government for years.
They have thrown
everything at him,
all the types of malware
from different companies
has been thrown at him.
And he received a few messages--
SMS messages that said-- he
is a human rights activist.
So it says, here's--
it's like a news article--
evidence of torture to activists
in the United Arab Emirates.
And there's a link.
He's savvy enough to know that
these might be fishing attacks.
This might be an attempt to
compromise his cell phone.
So he contacts the Citizen Lab,
which is a laboratory that's
part of the
University of Toronto
that does lots of security
research and told them, hey,
I received these messages.
And Citizen Lab, what they
did was they put it in a phone
that they could monitor.
And they clicked on it
to see what happened.
And two things happened.
First, they discovered three
exploits in the iPhone.
If you have an iPhone,
in September or August,
you received as an update
on the operating system
that patch patches those
vulnerabilities that
were found, thanks
to Ahmed Mansoor
and to Citizen Lab's work.
And also, Citizen Lab was
able to see what happened
and what the phone did and
who did it connect with.
And they were able to
map the infrastructure
of this Israeli company
called NSO Group.
And they were able to also map
all the domain names that were
associated to those servers.
So they got a list off
of over 200 domain names,
which Citizen Lab classified
by country, basically,
by analyzing either whether
those domain names are .mx
or they offer a service
that is only sold in Mexico.
It's sometimes these
domains try to impersonate
legitimate businesses
or newspapers or media
organizations.
So it was pretty easy
to classify it that way.
And they published
this investigation
that I urge you to visit.
It's called "The Million
Dollar Dissident."
They published this
in August 2016.
And they showed this chart.
And I saw this chart
and said, oh, Mexico
is the biggest chunk
of that pie chart.
So that means, most
domains used by NSO
as bait to infect
phones with malware
were associated to Mexico.
That told me, well, there must
be a lot of clients in Mexico.
And there must be
lots of victims.
In that investigation,
Citizen Lab
was able to also
identify a tweet
from a journalist in Mexico
that says, look at this.
Well, just a little
bit of background.
This journalist, with
other journalists,
uncovered one of the biggest
corruption scandals in Mexico.
The President of the
country and his wife
received a big house,
very expensive house,
almost for free,
from a contractor
that later got lots of contracts
from the Mexican government.
This became known as the
Casablanca Scandal, the White
House Scandal, because the
house he got was white.
And this was one of
the main journalists
working on this story.
And after they
published this, they
become enemies of
the state basically.
The main journalist that I will
talk about a little bit later,
Carmen Aristegui, she was the
biggest and the most listened
news radio show in the country.
She lost that, because
of the pressure
the government gave
to the radio station.
And there were lots
of threats, et cetera.
And he interpreted
these SMS messages
he received as a threat, because
the SMS message he received
said something like,
the Presidency will
sue for defamation to those
that published the Casablanca
report.
And he tweeted, like, I'm
receiving these messages.
It's not funny.
He thought there were threats.
But they were actually attempts
into infecting his phone
with this malware sold
by this NSO Group,
this malware called Pegasus.
Just to explain a little
bit more of the messages,
you will see it in
other examples later,
but it says
[SPANISH] unotv.com--
that's a media organization.
That's a news portal.
And they use a shortener.
But once you analyze that
link, instead of unotv.com,
which is a legitimate
site, it leads
to unotv.net, which is
one of those domains
that The Citizen
Lab was able to map
as part of NSO infrastructure.
But we still didn't know that.
We just saw this in the report.
We saw the pie chart.
We saw that there
was this suspicion
that there were these
journalists in Mexico that
had been, also, targeted
with this technology.
And we started to try to find--
oh, I got a little jumpy--
we started to try to find
the Ahmed Mansoors in Mexico.
Who are the targets in Mexico?
And we eventually
found a bunch of them.
If you looked at "The New York
Times" in February or June
or four times that this year
has been in the front page
in collaboration,
an investigation
that we have done--
these cases-- we ended up
in "The New York Times."
They talk about how we have
found more than 20 people that
have been targets of
this Pegasus Malware.
That we called this
investigation [SPANISH]
Investigation.
It was a big scandal
in Mexico, particularly
after June 19,
which we published
and "New York Times"
published and Citizen Lab
published this investigation.
It became a big
scandal in Mexico,
because we basically revealed
that all these people--
or these people's eyes--
were surveilled.
And I'm going to speak to you
about, who are these people?
And what does it say about
the situation in Mexico?
For example, there is this case.
This is a human
rights organization
called Centro Prodh.
It's one of the biggest and most
important operations in Mexico.
They've been
representing families
of human rights abuses--
the most high-impact abuses, for
example, killings by the Army.
Or there was a very high-profile
case that maybe some of you
have heard about the
disappearance of 43
students in 2014.
They represent the
families of those students.
It became a huge scandal.
Huge protests in the streets.
It almost toppled
the government.
And they've been in a
very contentious position,
because the government
has been put
in lots of articles for that
investigation to happen.
And they have been
representing the families that
want to know what happened with
their kids, which are still
disappeared.
And three people inside
that organization
received this Pegasus
infection attempts.
For example is
Director Mario Patron.
He received a message that says,
the Mexican government fools
GIEI.
GIEI is a group of
international experts
that was brought
into the country
to investigate the disappearance
of the 43 students.
This group of
independent experts
was brought to the country
because of the pressure
that happened on the
streets, in the media,
in the scandal that was putting
pressure on the government
to accept this
independent investigation,
because people were
rightfully suspicious
that the official investigation
was not going to lead anywhere.
And he received something
that is very important.
And we did this analysis
with all the messages
that we were able to document.
He received this message.
It was four days before this
group of independent experts
published their final report.
And it also received
the message the same day
that a group of forensic
analysts, independent analysts,
were-- because the official
theses or the official story
by the government is
that the 43 students were
burned in a dumpster.
However, there is scientific
evidence that shows that this
cannot be true, that the
dimensions of the fire would
have leaved traces of it.
And it was not possible to do
it in the way and the place
where the government
says it happened
and when it says it happened.
And this forensic analysis
showed the scientific evidence
that this was not true, that the
story that the government used
to cover up what
happened was false.
So it was a very highly tense
moment for the organization
and a contentious situation
between this organization
and the government.
And that's exactly when he
received these messages.
And then, for example,
there's this--
I already talked about them--
Aristegui Noticias, which is
an independent news portal.
Carmen Aristegui, she's one of
the most important journalists
in Mexico.
She revealed many scandals--
the Casablanca Scandal.
She has received
lots of pressure
by many governments and even
its own broadcasting company,
which she worked for
these investigations.
And we have been able to
document more than 50 messages
received to her, her
son, who actually
lives in the United States--
he received messages--
and other two journalists
of Aristegui Noticias.
They also received
these messages
in moments in which they
were revealing information,
they were revealing stories that
were particularly uncomfortable
for the government.
There's another case.
Carlos Loret de Mola-- he's
also a very famous broadcaster.
He's like-- I don't know-- like
an Anderson Cooper of Mexico.
He's a very famous news anchor
from a very big broadcasting
company that has actually
been seen by Mexicans
as very close to power.
But still, he also
received messages.
And particularly, he
received, for example,
this message impersonating
the US Embassy, saying,
we detected a problem
with your visa.
Please come to the Embassy.
See details and the link.
And that link was a
link to infect his phone
with Pegasus Malware.
He received six messages in a
month in which he was covering
a story of a federal
police killing of civilians
in one small town in Mexico.
Particularly, when he
was covering that story
is when he received
his messages.
And apparently, the
government was--
and I will later
explain why I think--
why there's evidence
it was the government--
was trying to surveil him.
All these people have--
and these are just
three examples.
But you can see in the
report, if you read
Spanish, more and more cases.
And they all have
one thing in common.
They were working as journalists
or human rights defenders
in things that the government
didn't want them to work on.
They even targeted the
GIEI, which I talk about.
These experts that were
invited into the country
to investigate the disappearance
of these 43 students
were actually surveilled.
And this is the most
outrageous thing to me.
There are 43 kids disappeared.
And you pushed all
this legislation.
And you bought
all this equipment
by using the argument
that you need
these tools to prosecute
crime and to prevent
these bad things to happen.
And instead of using
that surveillance
to find the students
and to find those
responsible for
his disappearance,
they used it against their
lawyers or their families.
They used it against
independent experts
that were brought
into the country
to investigate the situation.
And this really shows
what's the problem and what
the consequences of
this surveillance.
This was also in
"The New York Times."
This was the third
publication that we
were able to get
"The New York Times"
to cover in their front page.
There was a fourth
one, more recently.
But in general,
again, this shows,
now we are closer to not looking
like a tinfoil-hat paranoid.
We found them.
We found the victims.
We found the stories.
We've found the
connection between them
and the government.
And we found more stuff.
We found that the NSO Group
only sells to governments.
We found that each target
costs around $70,000.
And the Mexican government
spent at least $80 million
in acquiring targets.
Because the way it
works, you buy targets--
the ability to
target 500 people,
which was what one Mexican
authority purchased.
And we also found that
the Mexican government
acquired and used Pegasus.
We have contracts.
We have the bills that were
also leaked and published.
So it's clear now.
It's without a doubt that the
Mexican government has Pegasus.
That its main
opponents-- journalists,
human rights defenders--
were targeted.
And still, the government
is claiming, oh,
we'll investigate, it was
a coincidence, or whatever.
So the worst part right now
is that the prime suspect
of carrying out this
surveillance, the authority
that purchased this
Pegasus Malware,
is the same authority that is
in charge of the investigation
of the spying.
So we presented a lawsuit
against [INAUDIBLE],, which
is like the Department
of Justice of Mexico,
or the federal prosecutor,
attorney general,
which is the prime suspect of
being behind the surveillance.
Because it's the only one that
has accepted and documented
that it has acquired
this malware.
So we don't look [INAUDIBLE] for
tinfoil-hat paranoids anymore.
I think, this was a big scandal.
It was weeks and
weeks in the news.
It even forced the President
to make a statement.
He did, as usual, a
horrible statement.
We publish on Monday, June 19.
And on Thursday, he
went on TV and said,
I'm instructing the
prosecutor to investigate
those to have revealed this
story, because there are lies.
Then he backtracked.
Because actually,
there's no law that
can be used against those
that have been publishing
this information.
But still, the damage was done.
There was outrage as well.
And at least in the media and,
I think, in the general public,
it is established that
the Mexican government is
spying on journalists and
human rights defenders.
But that's not satisfying to
me, because those responsible
are still free.
They're not in jail.
And this is probably
still going on in Mexico.
So there's still a
lot of work to do.
We are doing a lot
of stuff, trying
to get justice in this case.
Not only because,
as I mentioned,
of the spying itself, but
because of what it represents
and because, instead of using
these tools to prosecute
the corruption that this
government has been found
to be doing, the human rights
abuses that this government has
been assisting or
covering up, it's
being used against
those that have exposed
or have demanded
justice in Mexico.
And I think that's something
that is not acceptable
and something that, if we
leave it as just an anecdote,
will repeat itself
and, probably,
will be more and more difficult
to detect and to resist.
But we're still fighting.
And probably-- yeah.
We hope this story
continues and continues
with people responsible for
this being held accountable.
And just to finish
and, maybe, open up
for questions, if you
have them, there's
a lot that a lot of
people can do to help.
First, by knowing about these
cases, by letting others
know about these cases and--
for example, as a
company, being very aware
about these type of governments
that have these intentions
and have these resources.
And they will use them.
And they will actually use
them against your customers.
They are using it
against Android users.
And they're trying to find
holes in your equipment,
to try to surveil on
human rights defenders,
on journalists.
So I think it is
important for Googlers
to know about these
type of cases to,
try to understand what
people on the ground that
use your services
are fighting against
and what you can do to help.
And I think there's
a lot of things.
And there's a lot of things
that Google has done.
Actually, this may be a
little inappropriate to say.
But it's true in a way.
For example, Google has done
a lot of things in encryption.
And it's great.
It's great that there's
encrypted from point-to-point.
But just-- and this is
no criticism of Google.
It's important to-- don't
think that that saves people
like these journalists,
human rights
defenders from being surveilled.
Because actually,
what it has led
is from governments
to buy malware to try
to go around encryption.
And well, then, if I cannot
my in-the-middle attacks,
because I will only
get encrypted data,
I will hack your phone and
get it before you encrypt it.
So it's important to always
think about the next step
and how you can
continually improve
the security of your
products and your services.
Because the other side, it's
always also looking in ways
to go around the
things that you create
and you come up with to try
to protect your users more.
So I encourage you to
keep thinking of this,
to be in contact
with us, to also
know what the needs are
in the ground, et cetera.
And I thank you for your
time and for your interest
in this story.
And let's keep fighting.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know if anyone
has any questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
You talked about how the
government is targeting
specific people
and they're going
after people who they have,
essentially, grudges against.
What sort of efforts are
there or should there
be to educate those people
and figure out whether or not
people are targets
of surveillance?
I know Google does
some sort of stuff.
But it's difficult if you're
using a outdated phone
or whatever.
Is that something
that you work on?
Or are there more
opportunities there?
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA:
Well, definitely, there's
people working on that.
And there is opportunity there.
There's both.
And I think, one of the
main positive things
about uncovering this is that
many people have become aware
of these threats.
Because, for example, the
first publication we did
was in February.
And after we published that
one case, many more said, hey,
I saw that story.
And I think I have
the same messages.
So the awareness also
protects, because people now
are more wary about proceeding
SMS messages with links.
And I would say that
most human rights
defenders and journalists--
at least if you read and
you noticed these cases,
you are way more wary.
But there are still
a lot of need.
There's a lot of
organizations that were not
taking security serious.
And after these case,
they say, OK, now we
have to devote resources
and time and effort
into building protocols
and systems that allow us
to be more secure in our work.
So definitely.
And I think there's
room for doing stuff
and for helping guys develop
those strategies to try
to protect themselves.
And I think, whatever you
guys can do to approach them,
because there are
so many in risk,
it's a great way to also help.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
the government's stands to--
or what does the
government think
it stands to gain from
spying on these journalists?
Is it more than just trying
to stop these stories
from publishing?
Do you think that they
have malicious motivations
to ruin their lives beyond that?
Is there any evidence?
LUIS FERNANDO
GARCIA: Well, there's
a bunch of consequences
that come from spying.
And there's different levels.
And we have seen them all.
We have seen, in some cases,
just gathering information
for later use, intimidation,
or other more nefarious
situations.
There's been actual
cases of intimidation,
of leaking that
information into the press,
and create reputational
damage to yourself
or your organization.
But you have to understand
that, in Mexico, the line
between government and organized
crime is, in many times,
non-existent.
So surveillance has a
potential use or a potential
to contribute to even harm
and death to these people.
Mexico is one of the
most dangerous countries
for journalists.
I think, outside of
Syria, is the country
where most journalists have
died in the last years.
Just this year, there's been 11
journalists killed in Mexico.
So there's many ways
in which surveillance
can be used against
these people,
either just knowing
their strategies
and trying to anticipate them.
For example, you're a
human rights organization
and I know what you're
going to say in a meeting
or in a lawsuit.
And then I can try to--
that intelligence helps
me counter your strategy.
But it can also be used
to affect your reputation.
I've seen many sick
stuff, like, trying
to even create just personal
problems with your wife.
Or there's some messages
that says, oh, look
at this video of your husband
having sex with another person,
and stuff like that.
So there's also an intention
on creating this turmoil
in your life.
So just, it's an obstacle
for you to conduct your work.
So it's a whole range,
from just knowing
and to reputation to even
harm or even getting killed.
And who knows what else
they might be using it for.
AUDIENCE: Do you know if your
organization was ever targeted
by the Mexican government?
And what about
your own security?
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA:
They always ask this.
I can't answer that question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA: But of
course, it's a consideration.
If you work-- basically,
if you do anything
that the government doesn't like
in Mexico, you are a target.
You need to think
about these things.
And we think about
these things as well.
Our threat model
definitely increased
after these publications.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm, thanks.
This question-- another
question, different person.
What your investigation
or research has uncovered
is alarming.
Thanks for sharing
in this forum.
Generally speaking, what is
your advice or recommendation
for people who may be
targeted of surveillance?
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA:
First, don't click the link.
That's the first thing.
Don't click any link that--
if someone sends you
something and you're not sure,
ask that person, hey,
did you send me a link?
That's the first thing.
And the second is to contact
us or other organizations that
are on the ground or outside
of Mexico that are doing
work trying to detect this.
Because it helps.
For example, Ahmed Mansoor--
who is actually in
jail, and I think
everyone should try to do
something to get him out
of jail, for example--
he did a great service to
millions of users of iPhone.
Because thanks to his savviness
and with the collaboration
he did with Citizen Lab three
security holes in the iPhone
were patched--
thanks to him detecting them.
So I think more collaboration.
I think this also [INAUDIBLE] is
an example of the collaboration
that needs to happen between
different organizations
to tackle this problem.
Because it affects many people.
And we have different knowledge.
I have the relationships.
Because building this trust and
relationships with the victims
is something that takes
time, effort, et cetera.
And we've been lucky
enough and to be
able to build
these relationships
and be able to get
these messages.
But we collaborated
with Citizen Lab
to try to analyze them and
have all the technical evidence
on the cases.
And I think,
definitely, for example,
in the case of Citizen Lab,
have collaborated with companies
even to also give them, in
a responsible disclosure
procedure, information
about these holes,
so they can patch
them, et cetera.
And I think, for example,
this is something
that I know Google
has been working on.
There's been multiple
occasions on how
they are trying to detect
attacks from malware developed
by NSO Group.
And I think this
is something that
is very important,
the collaboration
between institutions, civil
society, academy, corporations,
to try to detect and
protect users of technology.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you, Luis Fernando--
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA:
Oh, thanks to you.
SPEAKER 1: --for
joining us today.
And thank you, everyone.
LUIS FERNANDO GARCIA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]